hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
Sark's is using these philosophical
terms essence of existence and you
probably you've encountered the term
essence before in other contexts but not
necessarily in the way that he's doing
and in existence you probably haven't
used that term too much probably haven't
used it as nouns that something exists
right what is let's start with the
existence instead of starting in essence
what is your existence it's the you that
that's here the individual that's in
front we look around the room and see
each other and you know there's an
existing person right there
here's another existing person here's
another
there's another one and we have all
these different characteristics that
make us us and you could look at it at
any slice of time and say okay I'm six
foot three there's a couple other guys
in here who I think are about that tall
and then almost everybody is going to
short right that high that's part of
your existence not only particularly
important part I have dark hair red near
blondish hair other dark hair somebody
could have no hair you know I have hair
on my face not everybody else does
that's part of my existence that could
change right I could I could shave
tomorrow get rid of it get rid of this
hair the clothes that you wear that's
part of your existence the the habits
the ways in which you approach things
those make you you as well your memories
making you that's part of your existence
your history the fabric of relationships
that you're stuck with them for better
for worse
your loves your hates all of that is
part of what makes you the being that
you are that's part of your existence an
existence is what's actually there now
sarcasm as an atheist so he believes at
a certain point in time your existence
will come to it out he doesn't believe
in an afterlife someday you're going to
die and that's it so your existence
began and it will end and everybody else
we're overlapping what about SS when we
use the term essence
when when do we talk about assets or
licenses [ __ ] like that you know is
there any connection between that what
we're talking about here what's the
essence of a nerve yeah go ahead man I
was just gonna say like what makes it
exactly yeah
now again is there an essence to an herb
you know why don't talk about essential
oils well they smell like the thing so
if it's lavender it's most very lavender
it smells like what it ought to be and
you know individual piece of lavender me
not actually smell like that there's you
know little small differences it's gone
stale maybe Bob got into it and made it
you know smell bad but the essence is to
smell good in a certain way are their
essences to other things you know what's
probable thing about this right wallet
SARP uses the example of a knife and a
knife it's going to not only a certain
rationale or some characteristics it's
got a purpose this does - doesn't you
know I'll recognize this as an object
and what kind of object it is you graft
somebody like aerosol it so you grasp
its essence that's what it is
what's this for holding things yeah can
I use it for other things like you know
if it's raining I could keep the wreath
up in my head a little bit yeah but
that's not the purpose and you know it's
used sart's example of a knife
you know you can use a knife for other
things but you might hurt yourself that
way like if you try to clean your here
with a knife that's not a good actor yet
why because the purpose of a knife is to
cut things and it's
it's a good knife it's good at that and
if you mess around with your ear with a
knife you're probably going to cut here
in your ear because that's what it's for
there's a lot of other things you
probably shouldn't do with knives -
right you could think of well that's all
part of what makes the thing the thing
and it's easy to think about knives and
water bottles or boots or objects like
that what about human beings what is it
that makes us us well you know think
about our bodies first good well it
makes you you that's part of your
existence that's part of it yeah exist
your existence is complex but I don't
have your experiences you don't have
mine ah well we're going to get to that
that your that's that's good you're sort
of jumping ahead to where starts at this
point but then the four narrative is
that you and I have something in common
that that we share beyond our individual
existences and think about it your your
woman on man so already gender is
different I'm twice your age of guessing
you're not you're probably 2021 probably
the you know other than speaking English
growing up in American up and having
long hair we don't actually have that
much in common but we do have something
if you think about our bodies how many I
should be have 3 - yeah if you have 3
there's something something went wrong
something right and if you only have one
eye then we say you're oh you're recycle
if you only have what I usually read say
you're missing at night right
why because we're referring to the way
things ought to be we say there's
something wrong or something that went
amiss you have a certain basic form and
you know if you wanted to talk about in
bodily terms we can think about our
genetic code our genetic codes are
extremely similar all of us together we
should be shared 98% of our DNA in
common with chimpanzees so you go to the
zoo that chimpanzee there is 98% the
same thing as you down to that genetic
stuff that 2% makes a big difference
right and that 2% determines a lot of
the other things that make us vary from
from each other that's all part of what
makes you you but it's also something
that we're supposed to share across the
species what if we get to things that
aren't just bodily though is there
something and we all have in common in
other ways some of the other people were
to study this semester and say yeah
there's you know rationality as the
human beings are the rational era song
will define it I kind of like other
things that we are distinctive to us too
like laughing and crying animals make
noises but they don't actually laugh and
have a sense of humor in the way that we
do maybe that's distinctively human
religion you don't see cats setting up
shrines to some cat god that's something
distinctively human maybe that's of our
essence and so there's an older idea
about the sort of stuff that says yeah
we do have an assets and Sartre is going
to tack two different ways of looking at
this one is if you think's coming from a
religious view and whether or not you
got religion right you know that's
that's kind of available he's kind of a
reductionist about it but it is a his
view of it here's the way religious
people see things you have in essence
why do you have in essence because God
created things that like God you know
make each animal different than the
others so lions have their own assets
and cockroaches have their own essence
and we have an essence too and God you
know creates individual human beings
it's sort of like making a knife God has
an idea of the knife in mind before en
then he makes it come into being and so
if that's the case then how can you tell
if you're a good human being or not
whether you're realizing that essence if
it's part of our essence to say live in
harmony with each other like Thomas
Aquinas would say he thinks is that's
something reason can show us that that
we have a natural instinct for
and you don't live there any people in
City go around beating everybody up and
you know getting that stealing from them
well then you're not very good human
being in your existence go one side you
go around and do the opposite take care
of the people who got mugged
I guess we're good it would be good I
was gonna say like with the whole life
essence thing though like what you're
just going through the whole purpose
yeah if like we're talking about
anything like being everything is
created for like the sole purpose and
then like all things like are you saying
like you would be say we all share an
essence or whatever it like it's human
equals their essence we all serve the
same purpose
yeah that's this sorry that's what do
the sarcasm is shutting up to a
connector good idea as I've said I guess
I'm saying like you live work but we all
serve the same purpose if not really any
it can't be any distinctions which can
be between maybe it's like yeah cuz you
like each individually each individual
although they might be human they want
each individual they all have a certain
different purpose well that could be the
way your existence aligns with dress
it's like for instance calm you and I
are both men I met somewhere down the
line you hope to get married have
children or something like that right
maybe I have children and one of the
things that say Thomas Aquinas where I
look at during the semester
says not only is procreation part of the
natural instincts that we have there's
also an inclination to raise our young
to take care of them to nurture am I
going to do that in exactly the same way
as you are no there will be things that
have to do with my existence that are
things in your exist near you I have a
different purpose that it might be for
your kids right well they would be
that's still the same general purpose oh
it has something to do with our essence
but it would play itself up differently
actual circumstances let me let me go on
from there so let's say we take out out
of the picture and we say well we're
going to atheists and we still want
there to be something like an essence of
human beings human nature so that we can
say that there's good and bad right and
wrong which way we ought to live the way
we ought to be you know people talk
about this when I say well you can take
out on the picture and morality doesn't
disappear right that's the part of the
drive behind the new atheist Sartre says
well that's basically just the same
thing you just substituting nature and
forgotten you're saying there's
something that creates an essence of
human beings and the existence of a
human being comes out of the act and so
you took out of the picture the
substitute of natural law or evolution
or whatever you like you're doing you
really having the same picture and he
thinks that both pictures are wrong
instead he says first you exist you come
out of nothing a void of meaning and
then now you inhabit a world in which
people talk about essence the nature
human being
all that sort of stuff but really
whatever you're going to be you're going
to decide you're going to make yourself
you're going to make whatever essence
you actually have so this is where we
get to like maybe in your essence is
different than my assets in this archery
of you the essence of human being for me
clearly has something to do with you
know living the life of mind don't you
know
also with some things that are not so
thin like clearly just by looking at me
you can tell that exercise is not a high
priority for me was it one-time pleasure
of enjoying rich food and laying around
turned out to be more important for me
right still committed to the life of
mine you're the way to your essence is
going to play out to be very different
I can tell by looking at you that
exercises it this is a priority for you
at least right and it should stay that
way too by the way I never regret
haven't changed my priorities and you
can think about this with that question
about which goods are motivating you
that's going to determine what you make
of yourself
yeah totally isn't just on that down
like you are we do so if you want to
change your
yes around you change your essence and
change your York yeah it's easier to
talk about the different but you're
right yes I get attention
yeah and that's something we're going to
talk about in more detail later in the
semester like how do we change habits
and how do we sort of change the
trajectory of our our values and the
ordering of goods
SARP things but isn't your essence
always changing them completely or it
may be your just mask were like let's
say you didn't want to work out you
still didn't want to work out but you
know you have to work out something's
like in the mentality of some doesn't
wanna work out well if I made myself
work out even though let's say I made
myself consistently work out even though
I don't like working out and quite
frankly the only reason why I used to
work out as I used to like working out
and then when that changed I no longer
did it so I consistently make myself do
that that would be a different assets it
would be ok that I don't like it I would
be saying something like what want to do
things that one doesn't like because it
is better for oneself then laying around
and watching TV and eating what you like
you know that would be a different
essence trying out a bunch of different
things and never actually sticking to
them that would be a different kind of
essence movement so does this make more
sense to you now but what he's talking
about with when he's talking about you
make your own essence you're deciding
what human beings ought to be like them
yeah but it's your personality part of
your essence like just how you adapt hi
suppose
insofar as it's not just a mad like
let's say there's certainly aspects of
personality maybe you don't have much
control over take people who are
depressed and mean medication because
they have a chemical imbalance
I don't think Sartre would say that
they're responsible for the depression
could something organic how they deal
with it what they make of it he would
say they're responsible for now if
you're if you don't have something like
that and you have a couple setbacks and
you allow that to making gloomy and
luteal time at Sartre would say that is
that is your your choice that made
yourself into that first and then he
distinguishes two different kinds of
choice to I'd like to so there's there's
like the fundamental choice deep within
here your being and then there's you
know later on choices he's not saying
that every time you go to the cafeteria
to decide am I going to pizza today or
noodles or a salad that you're actually
like determining your essence you know
any full sets but know nothing about it
if you say to yourself man I need to
lose weight I better start eating more
salads I'm going to stick to this that
would be determining your essence is
this this is more clear now I know there
may be some things that are still does
they want something of the purpose
perfecting here well certain things that
you are choosing what the purpose of
your life is